der walter derzeit das problem da sind
auch die auswirkungen der dürre 2018 zu
stören
so kommt es ja eigentlich kein
niederschlag von ende april bis
einschließlich november
womit wir uns dann hauptsächlich
beschäftigen werden mit dem rest des
jahres nämlich statt holz einzuschlagen
reist nach dem fertigstellen des fells
schnittes kann sich der forstwirt
entfernen und dann wird das kommando
gegeben und die maschine macht das ja
dann ferngesteuert und zieht dann im
zweiten schritt erst den baum
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es besteht seit 2011 ist von der uni
frankfurt entwickelt worden um
alternative baumarten für einen klima
gerechten und nachhaltigen waldbau zu
finden
die bäume stehen hier seit 2011 sind
alles mediterrane arten die im zuge des
klimawandels ohnehin ihre areal grenzen
zu uns verschieben werden
und das sind jetzt quasi testflächen
versuchsflächen die in den wald
integriert wurden um einfach möglichst
naturnahen versuch zu schaffen zu
schauen wie sich die bäume hier
entwickeln als ersatz fühle ich die
gleiche
[Musik]
die tiefe wenn auch weiterhin eine
daseinsberechtigung rhein main gebiet
haben in welchem ausmaß das stellt sich
jetzt die frage
[Musik]